do you want to do that like
tj mac bit that we were doing yesterday
oh yeah you know i feel i feel shitty
you know shout out to brian g alvarez
funniest guy on tick tock he's
incredible
top five funniest people on tick tock uh
hysterical dude um
characters kill me
i was just if you're not familiar go
look it up um
you know the man shopping at tj mac uh
anyway if you don't get this reference
i'm sorry
you're a [ __ ] loser but he's blowing
up right now as he all these like
celebrities that he yeah of course well
he just i would say that jesus christ
yeah nice dude dude it's so jealous man
yeah that's the celebs he's filming with
i've been watching him since before i
knew he was [ __ ] famous all right i
was looking for him same yeah okay no i
was like [ __ ] i got into him oh you
just happened to bring him up after he
sells a tv show all right dude
no we we talked about him
no no no no no we didn't yeah we did no
we didn't yes we did no we didn't dude
um you told me yesterday you were like
look at this guy he's funny now today
because he sold a tv show yeah you see
that video he did with joe jonas yeah it
did that's why i think he's funny now
yeah right right no he filmed with joe
jonas he filmed with um
reese witherspoon
like people he's blowing up people are
yeah deservedly yeah no definitely
deservedly he's hilarious yeah hilarious
characters and the his most like iconic
one there's the tj mac guy
well i was just
dying laughing at the idea of dark you
know like the darker version of that
[ __ ] where he's just like
my wife is mad at me because i
put a bomb in the target
so now
she's mad at me
i got the phone
looking up pictures of
dead animals
[Laughter]
now she's upset because i
want to run over a chicken
that's how we're gonna make chicken wing
now there's blood in the car
yeah
you don't know they're speaking of
horrible thoughts i had another violent
thought i was playing angry birds on the
plane
yeah it was in the head rest
actually yeah it was in the head rest
okay
um
because there's no wi-fi
[Music]
i have [ __ ] on my phone okay so i'm like
i guess i'm just i'm gonna be an ipad
kid yeah and it's really funny playing
angry birds while the plane is just you
can't
you can't really play right
so i'm just kind of like staring at the
art like
i wonder if the if the flight attendant
came around if she was like
wow you're the first person to ever play
that no i wasn't are you
holy [ __ ] there was another scene there
was a there was like an eight-year-old
beside you no no there's there was
progress on my headrest from like the
previous player oh really which was me
on the flight over there
i requested the same plane so i could
pick up where i left off
so i'm playing and i'm like i started
like laughing at myself and like
does anyone
i i start a picture i always go to like
i think future is just
like one of the coolest people in
existence so i always like think about
well i basically asked myself what would
future do
and i started laughing picturing future
playing angry birds on an airplane yeah
it's like
all his like [ __ ] jewelry just like
he's future and he's just
and so as and then i'm kind of staring
at the heart and i started thinking
like
this game is kind of dark like it's just
like a bunch of bricks falling on pigs
right and then i just started thinking
of like a true-to-life angry person oh
god
like
like a small bird in a slingshot
like
just like scent at a piece of wood and
it falls over
yeah it just knocks over a [ __ ] tower
of bricks and they just fall on a small
pig just
so jeffree star's house yeah yeah
that's that's a mr beast video right
there yeah yeah today guys we're playing
angry birds for real life yeah there's a
chicken in a [ __ ]
like those watermelon slingshots three
people
[Laughter]
i told this [ __ ] to spock and oman as
[ __ ] was like
yo yeah imagine they just put a
firecracker on one oh god just tie it to
the bird
[Laughter]
yeah it goes up super high and then
straight down to the ground yeah it
doesn't even make it
oh well then they push over a block of
ice onto a pig
just horribly violent
we stacked up 300 bricks and we'll see
if this small baby pig can survive all
our attacks what's up youtube kids yeah
back with angry birds in real life
a bunch of kids in the airport just
yeah yeah
watching bricks fall into small animals
meet our little cute pig
we named him after his dick
now my wife is mad at me because i play
angry birds for real but in real life
because i like when the breakfast
i explode the pig
it's crazy how like
how dedicated i am
how engaged i am with these characters
yes yeah this is the whole storyline and
him and his wife the universe it's
awesome it's really incredible this is
him right here
go follow him if you don't already yeah
brian jordan alvarez man yeah click that
one the australia no the one with a
small head this is my favorite i think
new york he must
this must be the best
accent a pretty well-known lifting
competition called the new york city
and new york state
uh lifters
and trainers
session lifting
um
lifting competition and
such an honor to be here because it's
such a small group it's like eight of us
some of the biggest lifters and the
lifters in the world and
barty of course is here cheering me on
and i just wanted to say
if anybody's in new york and they want
to lift a couple of heaps
up
i've got
white plates i've got uh
barbells dumbbells
um
basically a whole noble gym here so uh
love you guys and and cheer for me at
the at the performance please at the at
the competition you know what i mean all
right bye guys god yeah
that common nails it most believable oz
accent it really is it's like the best
one i've seen it's better than most
australians actually
you